it ushered in a new era of activism by
players
look at this
a powerful image to show football's
social conscience
kickoff in every premier league match
delayed as teams took a knee
a moment to reflect on racial
inequalities and injustice
players harnessing the spotlight of the
world's most watched league and one of
those decision makers in 2020 a premier
league winning captain is seeing change
far beyond the pitch
they've done the gesture is
achieved what he wanted to which was to
keep the conversation alive
and to initiate change and action and
you know in my opinion you know that's
happened so
to see it evolve to the next step and
see what that looks like
will be the next challenge only on five
match days will players now drop to
their knees starting with the premier
league season openers this weekend
similar and the players union leadership
hearing from the 20 captains that the
impact of the gesture had faded i think
ultimately it's a question of if you're
going to do it which is again the
personal choice of the players do it
convinced and do it knowing why you're
doing it and it looks as if they want to
continue to do it but probably making
sure that less is more
but discrimination is a scar across
football campaigners kick it out
reported a 41 rise in abusive incidents
in grassroots football last season
compared to the last full year before
the pandemic
children trying to find a way into the
game see why their heroes are using
their platform for more than just
playing
does raise awareness and i think we
should
continue taking the knee if they do it
every single game it doesn't get that
important whereas you do it once in a
while it like shows how important it is
it was the murder of george floyd in the
u.s in 2020 that galvanized sport
campaigning against racism
wilfred zaha
electing not to take the knee
kremlin players will no longer be seen
taking a knee every week but the abuse
they face will take longer to remove
from the game
rob harris sky news